>> DO YOU HAVE A DATE?
>> Vice President Harris: I
WILL KEEP YOU POSTED.
>> Gillian: IT HAS BEEN 79
DAYS SINCE PRESIDENT BIDEN IS
TASKED HER TO SPEARHEAD EFFORTS
TO TACKLE THE CRISIS THERE.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL OF ARIZONA
ALSO RUNNING FOR SENATE IN 2022.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
INTERESTINGLY, YOU ARE CALLING
ON PRESIDENT BIDEN NOW TO THROW
IN THE TOWEL, PACKED UP HIS
BAGS.
HE IS IN EUROPE AND GIVE UP THE
REST OF THE G7 TO COME HOME HERE
TO THE U.S. TO ADDRESS THE
BORDER CRISIS.
WHAT EXACTLY DO YOU THINK IS
GOING TO COME OF YOUR REQUEST?
>> THUS FAR, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION ESSENTIALLY TOLD
STATES LIKE ARIZONA AND TEXAS TO
BALANCE.
THERE IS A CRISIS AT OUR BORDER.
WE WERE JUST TALKING ABOUT OUR
NUMBERS.
IT HAS BEEN 79 DAYS SINCE
VICE PRESIDENT HARRIS WAS
APPOINTED.
YOU HAVE SEEN HIM AS 500,000
PEOPLE.
THAT IS THE ENTIRE POPULATION OF
MINNEAPOLIS OR KANSAS CITY
COMING ACROSS.
YOU TALK ABOUT THE IMPACT THAT
HAS ON THE ENVIRONMENT AND
HARDWORKING TAXPAYERS.
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS SPENDING
TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO
HIS HOUSE PEOPLE.
THEY ARE TRYING TO GET THE
BENEFITS.
THAT AFFECTS TAXPAYERS.
I KNOW AS A PROSECUTOR THAT THE
CARTELS ARE EXPLOITING NOT ONLY
THE PEOPLE.
THEY ARE EXPLOITING THIS CRISIS
TO DRAMATICALLY INCREASE THE
AMOUNT OF FENTANYL AND HEROIN
COMING INTO OUR COUNTRY.
THAT IS GOING TO AFFECT EVERYONE
IN THE ENTIRE COUNTRY.
THIS IS A CRISIS.
IT IS TO BECOME A GOOD STRATEGY.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS
DONE NOTHING.
THEY’RE GOING TO EUROPE.
PLEASE CARE ABOUT AMERICA AT
LEAST HALF AS MUCH AS YOU CARE
ABOUT EUROPE, AND YOU WILL BE
ABLE TO SOLVE THIS.
>> Gillian: AND IT APPEARS
THAT THIS IS FAST BECOMING A
STORY ABOUT CONFLICTING
MESSAGES.
ON THE ONE HAND, WE HAVE THE
VICE PRESIDENT SAYING THAT TOO
WOULD BE MIGRANTS DON’T COME
HERE.
DON’T COME HERE.
BUT THE REALITY THAT WE GET FROM
OFFICIALS LIKE YOURSELF SAYING
THAT IS NOT WITH THE GOVERNMENT
IS REALLY DOING BEHIND THE
SCENES.
CBP AND DHS ARE WORKING 24 HOURS
AWAYA DAY AND SEVEN DAYS A WEEK
TRY TO PROCESS HIS CONSTANT FLOW
OF MIGRANTS THAT ARE COMING
WITHOUT DOCUMENTATION.
WHO DO WE BELIEVE?
WE SEE THESE PICTURES FROM THE
GROUND.
THEY LOOK HORRIFIC.
DO WE NOT BELIEVE OUR OWN EYES?
>> WHAT IS THE OLD LINE?
WHO DO YOU WANT TO BELIEVE.
THE PRESIDENT OR YOUR LYING
EYES?
NOT ONLY DID THE STATS NOT LIE,
BUT THE PICTURES WE ARE SEEING
DO NOT LIE.
THE STATISTICS THAT WE HAVE SEEN
IN THE SEIZURES AND THE PEOPLE
COMING OVER.
THOSE ARE FACTS.
PEOPLE ARE ENTITLED TO THEIR OWN
OPINION, BUT NOT THEIR OWN
FACTS.
I HAVE A MESSAGE FOR THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
YOU WANT TO KNOW THE ROOT CAUSE
OF IMMIGRATION?
THIS IS THE GREATEST COUNTRY IN
THE WORLD.
INSTEAD OF SPENDING HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
CENTRAL AMERICA, SPEND THAT
MONEY ON SECURING OUR BORDER AND
GETTING RESOURCES TO BORDER
PATROL AND ICE SO THEY CAN
CONTINUE TO PROCESS THE
1.2 MILLION PEOPLE WITH
DEPORTATION ORDERS THAT THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS REFUSING
TO DEPORT.
WE HAVE A CASE PENDING A FEDERAL
JUDGE DECISION ASKING THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION TO FOLLOW THE
LAW.
COMPLETE THE LAW AND DEPORT
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN ORDERED TO